[Musik]
die Welt staunt und Rätsel wer hat die
ostsee-pipelines in die Luft gejagt
welche Folgen hat das für den Ukraine
Krieg und auf unsere Wirtschaft bringt
die Laufzeitverlängerung für AKWs
tatsächlich die Wände viel zu besprechen
heute Abend bei Villach 8 mit diesen
Gästen der deutsche Osteuropäer Europa
Historiker und Publizist Professor Karl
Schlögl sein Thema heute Abend ist ob
ein Kriegsende in Sicht ist Dr Erich
Fahrt er ist Brigadegeneral ade und war
militärpolitischer Berater der damaligen
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel seine
scharfe these wir brauchen eine
Außenministerin keine kriegsministerin
makroökonom und Autor Daniel Stelter
erst davon überzeugt dass Russland ein
energiekrieg gegen Europa führt last but
not least die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion das war jetzt
ganz schon viel Fraktion und Diplom
agraringenieurin Carina Konrad sie freut
sich über die Laufzeitverlängerung für
zwei AKWs und damit herzlich willkommen
bei viertel nach acht mein Thema heute
Abend ist viel mehr der Anstoß für eine
Debatte mit unseren anwesenden Experten
es geht um den pipeland Solar in der
Ostsee am Montagabend ist es in beiden
Pipelines Nord Stream 1 und Nord Stream
2 zu einem starken Druckabfall gekommen
die Ursache insgesamt drei legs in der
Pipeline die Präsidentin der
Europäischen Kommission Ursula von der
Leyen spricht von einem Anschlag auf die
europäische Infrastruktur und ich weiß
nicht wie es Ihnen zu Hause geht aber
ich muss sagen bei mir hinterlässt es
ein mulmiges Gefühl Experten der
norwegischen militärwissenschaftler und
Marina offizielator strömt geht von
Sabotage aus ein Leck an drei
verschiedenen Orten können nur die Folge
eines vorsätzlichen Akts oder Sabotage
sein strömen sieht nur ein möglichen
Akteur und das ist Russland hier würde
ich gerne Herrn Professor Schlögl fragen
was für ein Anschlag von den Russen
spricht oder ob das nur Mutmaßung ist
ich habe keine Verbindung zu
Geheimdiensten es gab ja schon eine
Information von der CIA die eine Warnung
ausgesprochen hat ich habe keine Ahnung
es ist gab eine Geschichte doch
auffällig die nicht aufgetaucht ist in
den Nachrichten das nämlich an dem Tag
an dem die Explosion stattfanden
gleichzeitig oder kurzer vor der danach
die Baltic pipe eröffnet worden ist von
Norwegen nach Polen und der einzige der
soweit ich mitbekommen habe darauf
reagiert hat war modernietzky der
polnische Außenminister und das könnte
darauf hindeuten dass es eine
Demonstration der
Verwundbarkeit der Vulnerabilität
überhaupt der ganzen Infrastruktur mit
der Gasversorgung ist und ich kann das
überhaupt nicht
ausschließen aber es müssen Profis
gewesen sein ein eine Event
durchgeführte Aktion aber wir werden das
bestimmt herausfinden und ist abzuwehren
das ist die russische Seite sein könnte
dass sie kein Interesse haben könnte das
kann man auch nicht sagen sie haben in
den letzten Jahren so viele
Provokationen durchgeführt um Chaos
anzurichten und
Chaos zu moderieren dass man das auch
nicht ausschließen kann aber wir werden
das alles rechtzeitig erfahren glaube
ich Herr fragt wie prekär ist die Lage
aktuell
ich glaube die Lage im im Kriegsgebiet
ist schon sehr prekär nicht also vor
allen Dingen jetzt mit Blick auf die
durchgeführten Referenten ändert das
natürlich so ein Stück weit die
scheinreferenten sind natürlich eh nicht
möglich ist natürlich scheinreferent
aber in der russischen Perzeption
sind das jetzt Gebiete die zu Russischen
Föderation gehören und das hat natürlich
eine eskalatorische Wirkung denn wenn da
mit Waffen Gewalt reingewirkt wird kann
Russland immer sagen jetzt wird Russland
angegriffen ist eine neue Qualität nicht
und dann kann er natürlich auch über die
teilmobil machen hochfahren zur general
mobil machen und diese Stichworte
Atomschlag sind ja schon gefallen er hat
dann natürlich auch wenn Russland selber
angegriffen wird in der russischen
Lesart natürlich das ist nicht unser
Verständnis dann kann er auch
tatsächlich im Waffenarsenal ganz nach
oben gehen also es ist eine sehr starke
eskalatorische
Wirkung einfach und für mich ist das
jetzt auch dieser Referenden diese
Schein Legitimität der Russen und die
russische Perfektion ist jetzt Russland
das ist für mich jetzt auch ein Stück
weit ein echter Wendepunkt ich des
Krieges nicht weil wir müssen jetzt
wirklich aufpassen dass wir nicht nolenz
wohlens wirklich in einen Weltkrieg
hinein marschieren wenn wir da nicht
aufpassen und wenn wir jetzt noch mal
auf die Pipelines kommen wir wollen uns
hier natürlich nicht in Mutmaßung
verlieren noch kann keiner sagen wer es
war das auch ganz wichtig zu betonen
aber spricht denn etwas für Sie dafür
dass es ein Anschlag von den Russen war
ja so gut ich meine bei solchen Dingen
wo man kaum Informationen hat es war
eine hochkomplexe Operation das stimmt
was ja schlö gesagt absolut diese
Stellen waren 50 km weit weg ich würde
auch sagen das waren Wochen der
Vorbereitung und die Entscheidung dazu
die ist vor Monaten gefallen das glaube
ich kann man sagen und das ist nicht von
irgendeiner Terrororganisation das waren
wirklich Profis welche Profis haben fast
alle Armeen dieser Art die Navy Seals
sind für mich die besten aber das heißt
nicht dass Amerika das war aber für
Russland ist das natürlich also irgendwo
müssen die Russen ziemlich durchgeknallt
sein wenn sie es wenn dies gemacht haben
da wo ist das rational ich meine das
kommt für mich eigentlich als letztes in
Frage aber wir wissen es nicht das ist
jetzt Rande Spekulation
Herr stellt ja wenn sie darauf blicken
was macht das auch mit Ihnen
es verdeutlicht mir einfach nur dass wir
in der Tat von erweiter Eskalation des
Krieges stehen und wir sind natürlich
links Partei ich meine wir halten uns
zwar raus wer sind sich kämpferisch
aktiv aber wir sind natürlich längst
Partei wir sind wirtschaftlich betroffen
es zeigt die Anfälligkeit wobei ich dazu
sagen muss ist bedarf durfte nicht der
Anschläge auf die Pipelines um uns zu
zeigen wie anfällig wir sind bezüglich
Energieversorgung ja das ist eigentlich
eher jetzt ein weiteres Beispiel mit
Partei weil Kriegsparteien sind wir ja
noch nicht na gut aber wir haben
natürlich ein richtigerweise auf die auf
die Angriff Russlands ja mit Sanktionen
reagiert wir haben gesagt wir gehen im
Prinzip mit euch in eine wart
Wirtschaftskrieg hinein wir wollen euch
dafür bestrafen wir wollen das ja
aufhört und haben das gemacht mit
Sanktionen und die Sanktionen haben wir
immer weiter glaube ich heute kommt
diskutieren wird das siebte Paket oder
6/7 Verkehr auf EU-Ebene und dieses
führt natürlich dazu dass der Partei
sind wir sagen ganz klar wir sind an der
Seite der Ukraine wir möchten Druck
aufbauen auf Russisch zu denken wir
schicken ja auch Waffen ja gut der
Westen
also ich glaube der Punkt ist natürlich
ist es so wir sind dahingehend Partei
wir haben als der Krieg begonnen das
haben wir gesagt wir sind auf seine
Ukraine und wir möchten Russland alle
Anreize geben den Krieg zu beenden und
das tun wir über Sanktionen und damit
haben wir eine ganz klare Position
bezogen richtig die Frage das wäre mir
doch diskutieren sicherlich ist ob wir
auch die Schlussfolge runter ausgezogen
haben nämlich wenn man so eine Position
bezieht dann muss man auch kampffähig
sein übertragene Sinne auch jetzt nicht
militärisch sondern muss wirtschaftlich
sein und es ist genauso wenn ich jetzt
hin gehe ich vor dass ich raus zum Boxen
und kann aber nicht Boxen das ist blöd
da muss ich schon hingehen ich muss
sagen wenn ich jetzt schon die Sanktion
mache dann muss mir überlegen was wie
wirkt es auf mich und wie muss ich damit
umgehen dass er Schaden für mich gering
ist Frau Konrad angeblich sind die
Pipelines dauerhaft zerstört was würde
das für Deutschland bedeuten also ich
beteilige mich nicht an Spekulationen
darüber was genau da passiert ist das
haben
sondern was es bedeuten würde
im Moment für Deutschland für die
Energieversorgung in Deutschland und
wir müssen einfach feststellen wir haben
auch in den letzten Wochen schon kein
Gas mehr durch diese Pipelines bezogen
und Russland führt einen
völkerrechtwidrigen Angriff gegen einen
Land in Europa und es war auch nicht
anzunehmen dass noch mal Gas durch diese
Pipelines fliegt von daher würde ich für
die Energieversorgung in Deutschland
sagen spielt dieser Vorfall keine
direkte keine direkte Rolle und hat
keine direkten Folgen aber und das wurde
auch schon richtig hier in der Debatte
gesagt wir befinden uns in einem
energiekrieg der auch gegen uns geführt
wird und ja stehen harte Zeiten stehen
bevor wir treffen im Moment in
deutschen Bundestag viele Entscheidungen
um hier die Folgen abzuwenden doch wir
müssen auch noch weitere Entscheidungen
treffen so viel ist klar werden sie den
Unternehmern wenn es dazu kommt dass ab
1 Januar 2023 vielleicht nicht mehr
jedes Unternehmen Gas bekommt werden sie
und der Bundestag die
Bundestagsabgeordneten das dann erklärt
dass es harte Zeiten sind und jeder muss
jetzt den Goethe engerstein es wird ja
alles unternommen dafür dass auch Gas
genügend da ist für über Winter
Einsparmöglichkeiten wurden nicht genug
auch so suggeriert wurden auch an die
Bevölkerung transportiert und die
Bevölkerung und auch vor allen Dingen
Unternehmen das darf an der Stelle nicht
vergessen werden haben auch enormes
Einsparpotenzial bei Gas generiert in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten das ist
aller Ehren wert doch die Frage die sich
stellen ist ja richtig wo kommt es in
Zukunft her die wir haben die
Voraussetzungen dafür geschaffen dass
wir auch Gas in Zukunft über LNG
Terminals beziehen können die sollen im
Januar das erste lng-terminal auch in
Betrieb genommen werden weitere werden
folgen das sind alles Maßnahmen die
ergriffen wurden doch die klar ist auch
Einsparung werden auch über Winter
weiter notwendig sein und die Frage die
sich ja dahinter versteckt ist der
kommen wir in eine Situation der
gasmangellage das hängt von vielen
Faktoren ab das wurde ja auch schon in
anderen Debatten auch mit der
Bundesregierung herausgearbeitet aber
die Frage ist tatsächlich wollen wir
können wir diese diese Härten abfedern
und dafür müssen wir jetzt alles tun das
muss ja klar die Regierung hat alles
richtig gemacht so verstehe ich sie
wegen ich habe nicht gesagt dass alles
Einblick gemacht wurde ich glaube das
kann keiner Situation für sich
beanspruchen zu sagen dass alles richtig
gemacht wurde das hier ist eine
Situation wie die gibt es keine
Vorbereitung in der Schublade das hat
mich kann Ihnen aber versprechen dass
wir
dass wir in meiner Fraktion auf jeden
Fall alles tun und alles begleiten und
auch ermöglichen was notwendig ist in
dieser Situation damit kommen wir zur
These von Herr Stelter weil ich glaube
er sieht das etwas anders ja ich sehe
das ein bisschen anders was ist meine
These bei einer Aussage wir haben jetzt
sieben Monate Krieg und wir haben vor
sieben Monaten gewusst was unsere
Achillesferse ist dass die
Energieversorgung Energie ist Leben
Energie ist Wohlstand und auch eine Zahl
zu nennen soll nicht so viele Zahlen
nennen aber vor dem Krieg hat die
Europäische Union ein Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes jährlichen
Wirtschaftsleistung ausgegeben für
Energie jetzt sind es 5%. das heißt die
Kosten explodiert und was wir jetzt
erleben ist eigentlich die Gefahr einer
vor allem nicht nur schleichen
stattfinden sagt gut stattfinden die
Industrialisierung in Deutschland wir
verlieren Wohlstand weil wir haben
natürlich wieder hier schon gespart
wurde gesagt das gespart und die
Wahrheit ist da spart er ist auf
Produktion jetzt schon stillgelegt
worden da sollte man sich für lobe sein
schlechtes Zeichen und ich werfe der
Regierung eigentlich vor dass sie nicht
gehandelt hat das war vor sieben Monaten
klar was passiert das heißt man hätte
alles tun müssen die energieversorge in
Deutschland auszuweiten alle
Kohlekraftwerke die funktionsfähig sind
anmachen alle Atomkraftwerke nicht nur
weil überlaufzeit über ein paar Wochen
diskutieren sondern über gleich sagen
wir bestellen die Brennstäbe es Angebot
lag auf dem Tisch von Westinghouse wir
hätten die brennstrebe wahrscheinlich in
diesem Dezember schon bekommen wir
hätten 6 Atomkraftwerke laufen lassen
können das wäre ungefähr 15% der
deutschen Strombedarfs wir hätten
darüber hinaus ganz schnell anfangen
müssen sagen der Fall feuern kein Gas
mehr für die Stromerzeugung ist so teuer
macht all das wurde nicht gemacht und
deshalb bin ich ganz andere Auffassung
die Bundesregierung hat sieben Monate
über Krieg geredet über die große Sache
geredet was er das machen würde und hat
die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht und der
Preis den wir zahlen ist ein bitterer es
geht ja nicht darum zu sagen ich
verhindern ein Blackout natürlich soll
man das verhindern es geht nicht darum
dass er eine gasmangelage verhindern es
geht dass wir die av8-fachung der
Energiepreise haben für die Wirtschaft
und das hält die nicht aus und letztes
Beispiel noch dazu als Corona war hat
man gesagt na gut wir schließen das
Restaurant das ist jetzt schade und es
macht ein paar Monate später wieder auf
ist er habe Herrn havix Modell paar
heute nicht da und dann geht wieder als
weiter er hatte funktioniert und es
nicht funktioniert hat da war es ein
anderer Wörter aufgemacht hat in der
Industrie ist das anders wenn
Fabrikation hier zu sind darf man nicht
davon ausgehen dass sie eine paar Jahren
wieder aufmachen werden hier das heißt
wir brauchen eine Strategie über die
energieangebote massiv erhöhen und da
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen da ist die
Bundesregierung in weiten Teilen
Entschuldigung eigentlich verloren auch
wenn ich gerade in die Kommunikation
Atomkraftwerk das wieder heute gehört
hat denke und zum zweiten hat sie auch
keine Antwort gefunden wie sie die
Firmen Schutz vor dem gasanstieg nämlich
noch ein Beispiel geben wir haben in
Deutschland gastvorräte die
entsprechenden Lieferung aus Russland
von 40 Jahren
wir fördern ihn nicht aus Umweltgründen
als wäre es umweltschonender in USA
Tracking zu betreiben und hierher zu
transportieren auf Schiffen es ist
völliger Irrsinn wir würden sagen wir
sollten ja auch wir müssen hier und
übrigens es hätte ungefähr sechs Monate
gedauert bis erst eine Gas geflossen
wäre wir müssen Dragon hier betreiben
selbstverständlich und das ist auch
immer eine Geschichte schwierig ist das
kann man alles machen in Deutschland
wird würde es beherrscht Technologie und
das wird eigentlich die Frage wo ich
sage das ist übrigens wo ich darauf
fasse und bin dass der Krieg viel früher
begann hat nämlich die Frage ist warum
entscheiden wir so viele Dinge nicht zu
tun warum ist so verpönt die britische
Regierung hat feigenverbot ist auch also
wir haben uns zu abhängig gemacht
Informationen das auch Russland bereits
schon die letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten
eigentlich schon Aktivitäten unterstützt
hat die gesagt haben wir machen kein
Tracking wir machen kein Atomkraft und
so weiter und so fort und das ist das
Ergebnis der ganzen Sache nur wir sind
ein Wirtschaftskrieg und es wird immer
erzählt dann bist du auch so handeln ich
kann nicht sagen ich bin im Krieg und da
mache ich ein bisschen Sandkasten Spiele
jetzt was passiert ist wir verlieren
unser Wohlstand ja aber gerade die ganz
großen Gewinner die haben in Amerika
kostet
in die USA und wenn die Wirtschaft hier
weg ist ist over aber lassen Sie uns
hier einmal noch mal ganz plastisch
werden was steht uns denn als Wirtschaft
bevor Massenarbeitslosigkeit was sind
die großen
Sachen anführerschein gute ist ja dass
die wir sowieso eine Schrumpfen der
wärsbevölkerung haben das heißt jetzt ja
Persönlichkeit wird langsamer zunehmen
was passiert ist wir verlieren
Schlüsselindustrie es würde
Chemieindustrie Wissen Ludwigshafen
würde ich heute abgebaut BASF geht nicht
weg nein aber der ist halt hat Standorte
in USA in China sonst war auf der Welt
die erhöhen dort die Kapazitäten und wir
gehen hier runter zu fahren das ist ganz
natürliches Verhalten die Stahlindustrie
Aluminiumindustrie Aluminium kostet der
Strom in Deutschland ist höher die
Stromkosten für ein Kilo einmal Linien
ist Deutschland ist höher als der
Weltmarktpreis das heißt wir machen
gerade ganz industrieplatz und dann
stellen wir uns hin und sagen ja wir
müssen nur sicherstellen kann der Decke
und gibt aber Freunde wir sind gerade im
vollen Tempo der demistralisierung und
verlieren diesen Krieg es nützt uns
überhaupt nichts wenn ein paar Jahren
dann die Ukraine wieder frei ist und
alles drum und dran alles ist frei wir
haben den Krieg aber verloren weil die
Branchen die wir verlieren die kommen
nicht zurück und vergessen wir nicht die
Welt beneidet Deutschland darum dass wir
immer noch seinen hohen anteilindustrie
haben solide Zahlen ungefähr ein Viertel
der Deutschen Wertschöpfung erfindet in
der Industriestaat das sind gut bezahlte
Arbeitsplätze wissen Sie wenn die alle
wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig in
Berlin mit der Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles Essig da
ist ja total statt Essig die rentenessig
die Krankenversicherung Essig es ist in
Deutschland ja auch die hidden champions
muss man ganz klar sagen ganz genau und
den wird natürlich auch geht es an den
Kragen Industrie wird dann gerettet also
Konzerne Personenhaushalte der
Mittelstand fällt weg die die global
aktiv sind die nicht aktiv sondern hier
am Standort sind die verlieren so massiv
an Wettbewerbsfähigkeit dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen dass es nicht mehr
existieren und ich bin ein ganz großer
Fan der FDP aber ganz ehrlich ihr seid
mit in der Regierung und was er Habeck
da anzieht ich weiß nicht ob sie jetzt
die die Industrialisierung beschleunigen
wollen und co2-zähler zu erreichen ich
weiß es nicht nur objektiv gesehen ist
es quasi was wir machen und wir fahren
gerade sagen vor die Wand und in der
Diskussion Atomkraftwerke verstehe ich
nicht ich würde mir auch eine Welt
wünschen wo ich nur mit Windrädern und
so einer wir haben sie aber nicht nur
mal zur Erinnerung für den gesamten
Primärenergiebedarf Deutschlands kommen
16% aus neuer bahnenergien 16 %, die
Hälfte davon ist Biomasse also die
Verbrenner Holz auf Band Biogas das
heißt 8 %, kommt das Wind und Salat und
wer ist denn das Doppelte haben und
übrigens ein letztes Wort gesagt na ja
er Habeck ist aber nicht an Schuld in
der Situation sind das stimmt
weil er hat nicht die gasabhängigkeit
gefördert die wird gleich sagen na gut
die Energiewende hat das hingetrieben
aber lass mal den Kredit aber er war im
Amt am 24 februar und er hat 700 Zeit
gehabt und davon zu bewahren uns hat er
nicht getan und deshalb kritisiere ich
ihn wir Fragen hier mal Professor
Schlögl auch als Osteuropa Historiker
konnte man das kommen sehen können was
jetzt passiert ist also war es möglich
diese Krisen dass das passieren würde
die Abhängigkeit zu sehen als Politiker
ich glaube die Radikalität des Einbruchs
des
zeitenbruchs das hatten kaum jemand
gesehen und selbst die ganz nah dran
waren an der Grenze an Aufmarsch an der
Front die Ukraine sie selber konnten
nicht glauben was am 24 Februar
frühmorgens passiert ist und deswegen
ist jetzt diese Rede dass man alles
schon hat sie kommen sehen und so weiter
das halte ich für eine Art von Bescheid
wisserei aber man hat bestimmte Dinge
doch gewusst und das erstaunlich ist
dass man nach der Krim Annexion das muss
man sich vorstellen nach der Annexion
hat man Dinge gemacht wie eben die
Verabschiedung der Pipeline wenn Nummer
zwei was ja eigentlich ein unglaublicher
Vorgang gewesen ist mit unglaublichen
Erklärungen dass das kein optisches
Projekt sei das ist keine geopolitische
Bedeutung habe sondern einen schlicht
kommerzielles Projekt so hat es Frau
Merkel gesagt oder man hat bis zuletzt
hat man Gasspeicher und Werke an die
russischen Unternehmen verkauft das ist
alles unglaublich und zeugt von einer
großen
Ignoranz nicht wissen wollen und aber
die Frage ist wie sich diese ganze
Komplex einer gewissen Ahnungslosigkeit
eines nicht wahrhaben wollen wie sich
das aufgebaut hat und das ist nicht die
Sache einzelne Leute nur sondern ich
glaube da muss man wie das ein Kollege
formuliert hat den deutschen Russland
Komplex mal auseinander nehmen zu dem
man vielleicht extra noch diskutieren
könnte aber die Radikalität des
Einschnitts mit all diesen Konsequenzen
glaube ich waren unabsehbar also wenn
sie jetzt
sehr katastrophischen Szenarien vom
Untergang des deutschen Mittelstandes
sozusagen der
Exzellenz der deutschen Industrie warnen
das ist natürlich ich nehme das sehr
ernst und ich kann auch nicht teilen die
Auffassung dass man Kohlekraftwerke
stilllegt in diesem Augenblick dass man
Atomkraftwerke nicht betreiben soll ich
teile diese Auffassung aber man muss
auch sagen dass die Regierung in sehr
kurzer Zeit den Ernst der Lage erkannt
hat und da muss ich habe den Schutz
nehmen er ist der Einzige der ganz klar
die Radikalität dieses Vorganges erkannt
hat was es heißt ein kontinentalkrieg
inmitten in Europa anzufangen das ist
der der ernste Sache und auf diesem
Hintergrund muss man die Entscheidung
sehen und dass man inzwischen eine
Diversifizierung der Energieversorgung
angefangen hat dass man den Grips
angestren rund um zu überlegen wie man
aus dieser Abhängigkeit herauskommt das
ist eine eigentlich große Leistung auch
in sieben Monaten Regierung
angesprochen die hat sich heute geäußert
das hat sehr lange nicht mehr getan und
da hören wir einmal ganz kurz rein
und heute möchte ich angesichts der
Entwicklung der letzten Tage ergänzen
Worte ernst zu nehmen sie nicht von
vornherein damit abzutun sie sei nur ein
Bluff sondern sich ernsthaft mit ihnen
auseinanderzusetzen das ist beileibe
kein Zeichen von Schwäche oder
Beschwichtigung sondern ein
ausweispolitischer Klugheit einer
Klugheit die dazu beiträgt
Handlungsspielräume zu erhalten oder
mindestens so wichtig sogar neue zu
erarbeiten das waren die Worte heute von
Frau Merkel sie kennen Frau Merkel sie
war lange ihr militärpolitischer Berater
erfahrt wie schätzen Sie die Worte ein
die sie heute gesagt hat ja sie hat ja
mit gerade mit Blick auf diesen
vermeintlichen Bluff des
atomwaffeneinsatzes eben gesagt im
Klartext man muss das ernst nehmen und
sie hatte richtig gesagt von politischer
Klugheit gesprochen deswegen müssen wir
was den Ukraine Krieg anbelangt
rauskommen aus dieser reinen
Kriegsrhetorik auf das
eindimensionale des der Lieferung die
sind wichtig also klar brauchen die
Waffen aber wir brauchen auch politische
kluge politische Lösungen das ist die
Message so wie ich sie hier sehe und das
fehlt hier einfach komplett neu und das
ist im Grunde genommen der Punkt wo ich
auch der Meinung bin das müssen wir
ändern ich es ist richtig der Ukraine zu
helfen militärisch Sie in die Lage zu
versetzen das sind militärisch nicht
untergebuttert werden aber wir haben
nicht das Interesse der strategische
Interesse in einem dritten Weltkrieg
reingezogen zu werden und alle 30
Staaten der NATO haben das nicht weil
ich und das vermisse ich in der
deutschen Außenpolitik es ist zu stark
fokussiert auf Waffenlieferungen und zu
wenig oder gar nicht in Richtung auf
politisch diplomatische Initiativen und
das Putin nicht verhandlungsfähig ist
also das ist auch ein armenmärchen denn
wir haben parallel zu diesem
fürchterlichen Überfall und Krieg in der
Ukraine haben wir haben wir immerhin
dieses getreideabkommen ausgehandelt
bekommen und das ist doch tatsächlich
gelungen mit den Vereinten Nationen mit
Putin nicht Erdogan ich muss auch sagen
der türkische Präsident der ist da
flexibler bei all den Nachteilen die die
Türkei hat die die Grünen wollen jetzt
wieder Sanktionen gegen die Türkei
aussprechen
weil da natürlich menschenrechtliche
desinstätte sind rechtschreiblichkeit
das ist alles in Ordnung aber
konstruktiver im Konfliktmanagement im
Krisenmanagement ist er bei all den
defizierten wir bei uns ist absolut Zero
ich will ganz ehrlich
wir haben eben nicht vom Bluff Thema
gesprochen sondern von der
pipeline-frage und da gibt es eine klare
falsche Entscheidung und es wäre
großartig wenn die ehemalige Kanzlerin
ermutigt und
großzügig wäre einzugestehen dass sie
eine Fehlentscheidung nein das war keine
Fehlentscheidung sie hat im Grunde
genommen der Werte kommt eher
Wertekompass gegenüber Russland war
immer klar ich war ja auch beim Treffen
dabei mit Putin die hat eben mehrfach im
Arsch geblasen aber sie hat es in einer
das hat ja übrigens auch gesagt in einer
volle Naht gemacht mir gefällt es auch
nicht dass Staatslenker man kann über
Putin sagen was man will kriminalisiert
werden ihre dargestellt werden krank
dargestellt werden wenn wir in dieser
Rhetorik das ist permanent der Fall wenn
wir diese Rhetorik reingehen dann
kriegen wir am Ende keine Friedenslösung
mehr hin das ist doch das was sie meint
wir müssen doch da raus es gibt keine
militärische Lösung ich habe das so oft
gesagt man kann einen nuklear macht
militärisch nicht besiegen und Russland
ist die stärkste nuklearme der Welt
können sie halt auch das größte
militärpotential der Welt das heißt
nicht dass wir uns alles gefallen lassen
müssen also wir müssen die NATO stark
machen wir müssen im Appetit auf
imperiales mehr nehmen das ist schon
vollkommen richtig ne aber wir müssen
vernünftig mit dem Content ja aber dann
können sie aber auch nicht
wirtschaftlich besiegen immer auch dazu
sagen die Sanktionen dauern viel zu
lange und man muss aber einer wir
besiegen uns wirtschaftlich damit
erstellt haben
wir haben erstmal das so die Tatsache
ist durch unsere Sanktionen der mehr
Geld ein als davor weil nämlich die
Preise stark gestiegen sind also er hat
sein weniger verkauft kriegt mehr Menge
und ich möchte noch mal sagen wo ich mit
identifiziert nicht einer Meinung bin
ich bin mit einer Meinung habe ich
sofort erkannt hat dass ein Angriff
richtig und er hat was getan
Diversifikation es war unstrittig ein
Fehler nur die auf die Pipeline zu
setzen und nicht zusätzlich noch einen
geht zu setzen und beide es war meines
Arzt immer noch ein großer Fehler auch
unter ökologischen Gesichtspunkt nicht
das Gasse fördern was wir im Inland
haben das muss auch das ist so ein
bisschen ja sieht man anderes warum bin
ich auch bei uns verstehe ich nicht aber
wie gesagt das ist die Historie jetzt zu
sagen er hat richtig erkannt ist ein
anderes wir befinden uns im Krieg wir
befinden uns ein Wirtschaftskrieg und
dann genügt es mit Verlaub gesagt es
genügt nicht was getan wurde ein
Terminal zu bauen ja dann fangen sie mal
die katharis haben die katharischen
Vertrag gemacht nein weil die katharis
haben gesagt wir hätten gern 20
Jahresvertrag warum haben sie das gesagt
weil die müssen ja auch Kapazitäten
aufbauen für Terminals und so weiter und
so fort dann wie gesagt nein nein in
drei Jahren dann wollen wir nicht mehr
also kommt das ja gar nicht das kommt ja
in dem Maße gar nicht und deshalb hätte
die anderen Maßnahmen auch machen müssen
es kann ich ihn konzidieren das ist eine
große großer Schritt ist für ein zu
sagen ich mag die Atomkraftwerke die
Kohlekraftwerke die grüne
Kohlekraftwerke kein Problem ist die
kohlepartei die haben die Kohle ja über
die Jahre wir sind ja deshalb so viele
Kohle weil wir die Kohle brauchen das
Backup da hätte mehr machen müssen dass
bei mir schon da ist sozusagen diese
Aktie erkennen der dramatische Situation
nicht in Einklang mit der
wirtschaftlichen wir der
Wirtschaftskrieg mit Russland wir
gewinnen denen nicht damit indem wir
kalt duschen und Waschlappen verwenden
den gewinnen wir nur indem wir den
rikosten runterbringen wenn sie wirklich
Russland Schwächen wollen müssen wir die
globalen Energiepreise runter kriegen
für Öl und vergaß ja das ist das
Russland gegen schlecht als es Öl 20
oder 30 Dollar war das heißt was müssen
wir machen wir müssen weltweit und in
die Ausbau von fossilen Energien wie der
investieren was im Jahre noch nicht
getan haben wir brauchen was sowieso und
wir müssen in Deutschland das auch tun
wir können nicht immer nur sagen macht
ihr mal und wir schauen wir müssen
mitgehen nur so gewinnt man gegen diesen
Gegner er vergeht wir nicht damit dass
wir jetzt sagen es gibt diese die
Industrialisierung und das dabei habe
ich dabei die Bundesregierung in den
sieben Monaten was getan aber sie hat
eben direkt an den kleinen Hebel
gearbeitet und hat die großen Hebel sich
nicht getraut anzugehen er stellt in
einem Punkt sind sich glaube ich sogar
Frau Konrad und sie einig nämlich dass
die Grünen noch mehr machen können
beziehungsweise ist die Atomkraftwerke
sollen das ist ihre Teesorte haben Frau
Konrad ja meine These die ich
mitgebracht habe ist tatsächlich die
dass wir jetzt einen guten Schritt haben
ja bei Kat aber schon im Juni gesagt
dass jede Kilowattstunde zählt und wenn
jede Kilowattstunde zählt zählt eben
auch jede Kilowattstunde unabhängig
davon wo sie erzeugt wurde und wie sie
erzeugt wurde dazu gehört ganz eindeutig
auch die Kernkraft in Deutschland weiter
zu betreiben über einige Monate im
nächsten Jahr hinaus weil das die
voraussetzung ist dafür dass Energie
nicht noch zusätzlich verknappt wird und
genau das Preissignal negativ
weitergesendet wird wie es im Moment
gesendet wer wir haben die Situation
dass die Preise enorm steigen das
zahlreiche Unternehmen in Deutschland
vor der Situation stehen Neuverträge
machen zu müssen ab Januar im Moment
angesichts der Verteuerung auch bei
Strom denn wir haben eine stromkrise
auch das wurde viel zu lange auch
negiert auch von Teilen der der Grünen
in dem Teil negiert wie es falsch war
und wie sich jetzt herausstellt dass
Unternehmen wirklich massiv unter
Bedrängnis geraten weil die
Kostensteigerung im Prinzip nicht
leistbar sind deshalb müssen die
Energieversorgung ausgedehnt werden die
jedes Kilowatt muss bereitgestellt
werden aus Kohle ausgas aber natürlich
auch aus der Kernkraft ich bin ja ganz
bei Hersteller der dann auch sagt wir
müssen auch darüber nachdenken wo haben
wir eigene vorkommen die wir vielleicht
auch für die Zukunft noch nutzen können
da sind wir beide nicht weit auseinander
aber wir müssen jetzt die richtigen
Entscheidungen endlich in die Wege
leiten ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir
das schon vor der Sommerpause auf den
Weg gebracht hätten und ganz ehrlich
zwei Kraftwerke von drei reichen nicht
wir sind im Wahlkampf in Niedersachsen
im Moment darf die Partei nicht vor dem
Land stehen und deshalb bin ich auch
dafür dass wir tatsächlich jetzt die
Kraftwerke weiter betreiben die noch am
Netz sind sie kommen direkt noch einen
Schritt weiter die realistisch
die Firmen die die Verträge abschließen
im Januar die Preis sehr in der
definiert auf den erwarteten Preisen das
ist Feinde das heißt es wird immer so
getan es nützt uns nicht Tracking dauert
sechs Monate wenn wir anfangen
führt zu einem fallenden Preis die
Ankündigung 6 Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen führt zu einem
massiv fallen den Preis darum aber das
ist ganz entscheidend ist für die
Unternehmen sollte die zukünftigen
Preise entscheidend und deshalb noch mal
an wenn er im Juni hat er das gesagt bin
in Kilowattstunde geschaut haben
innerhalb von sechs Monaten hätten die
eigengast die ganze nächste Produktion
es wurde die erste Gast wurde strömen es
gibt die technologiens ist ready go to
go die Maschinen sind greifbarer Markt
muss man im Prinzip die Maschinen kaufen
hinstellen es dauert ungefähr vier bis
sechs Monate man muss natürlich genauso
schnell genehmigen wie man die Energie
Termin ist genehmigt hat aber ich will
jetzt gar nicht darauf jetzt vorbei
wir sind im Wirtschaftskrieg und der
Wirtschaftskrieg wenn wir so agieren ja
das geht überhaupt wir können nicht
wirklich fühlen wenn jeder Flughafen
gebaut haben wir müssen den
Wirtschaftskrieg führen wie man
Wirtschaftskrieg führt ja hätte
Churchill so gegen uns gekämpft werden
Geschichte das heißt wir müssen ganz
ganz radikal vorgehen und das vermisse
ich einfach und Diskussion ist einfach
lächerlich ja die Diskussion überführen
sind lächerlich und im Juni unsere das
ist alles viel zu spät und das Problem
der ganze Sache ist wenn die Preise nur
auf dem fünffachen Niveau bleiben
das trifft die ganzen Bürger alle
Zuschauer trifft das ist drifte Firmen
und die Firmen sind nicht
wettbewerbsfähig das geht wir haben ein
Faktor zu USA von 1 zu 10
und das wäre eine Rolle Energie ist
Leben und wenn wir die ohne günstige
Energie ist der Wohlstand hinüber und
damit ist alles hinüber und übrigens
auch alle unsere Bemühungen zum
Klimaschutz kann man ja vergessen weil
dann können wir sie uns nämlich nicht
mehr leisten erstellt hat ja recht
Energie ist der dreh- und Angelpunkt für
unsere Wirtschaft das ist doch ganz klar
und das ist für jede Wirtschaft ich gebe
Ihnen Recht das ist doch ganz klar aber
sie tun so als hätten wir erst so
Energiepreise seit dem Krieg wir hatten
auch schon vorher relativ hohe
Energiepreise im europäischen im
weltweiten Vergleich und unsere
Unternehmen waren da auch schon in der
Lage dazu sich dem Wettbewerb zu stellen
das darf deshalb auch eine zu negativ
gesehen werden und wir müssen jetzt auch
dafür sorgen ah das Energie zur
Verfügung steht dazu gehört dann auch
einfach dass man in einer Krise mitten
in einer Krise nicht noch bestehende
Kapazität nichts anderes würde das würde
das bedeuten aber gerade LNG und das
Verfahren für LNG und die Schnelligkeit
mit der diese Gesetzgebung in Gang
gebracht werden konnte zeigt doch auch
was möglich ist
das zeigt doch auch was möglich ist in
unserem Land und das ist das was mich
antreibt nämlich jetzt auch zu
ermöglichen was geht um durch diese
Krise durchzukommen und auch für die
Zukunft den Baustein dafür zu legen dass
wir vielleicht dann tatsächlich
werden wir müssen uns hier jetzt mal
ganz ehrlich machen die Unternehmer in
diesem Land fühlen sich ja gerade von
der FDP eher verlassen als dass man das
Gefühl hat das Kampfmodus ist und Sie
haben gerade gesagt wir sollten das
jetzt alles nicht zu negativ sehen
vorher waren die Energiepreise auch ich
sage immer was sie haben eben gesagt man
wird sehen ab 1 Januar die Verträge
schon jetzt können mittelständische
Unternehmen in diesem Land keine
Verträge mehr ab 1 Januar 2023 mit E.ON
und Co abschließen die müssen jetzt
betteln gehen bei den Stadtwerken
betteln gehen bei den Grundversorgern
das heißt wenn ich jetzt Unternehmer
wäre und sie sitzen sehen würde die
sagen wir müssen da jetzt auch die
Krisensituation ist noch nicht so ganz
da würde ich ja ausrasten vor dem
Fernseher
sagen also wenn ich jetzt Unternehmer
aber ich würde ausrasten wenn sie sagen
was die ja auch aus und ich verstehe das
ja auch und die Situation wir haben ich
bin nicht Wirtschaftsminister in diesem
Land wir können nur alles tun um Energie
auch an den Markt zu bringen um die
Preise zu senken Marktsignale zu senden
wie sie gerade gesagt haben dazu gehört
tatsächlich mehr als als zu reden das
hat so lange gedauert das ist ja ohne
Zweifel aber jetzt dann auch wirklich
dahin zu gehen und zu sagen ja wir
machen das mit der Kernkraft wir
betreiben die weiter wir nehmen die
Kohle jetzt wirklich ans Netz und reden
nur darüber dass sie ans Netz gehen soll
wir schaffen auch die regulatorischen
Voraussetzungen dafür dass die
Kohlekraftwerke tatsächlich auch
hochgefahren und in Betrieb werden
können was ja was ja auch nicht
stattgefunden hat genau Sommer aus
vielen Gründen die Kohle wurde nicht
dahin transportiert jetzt haben wir
Probleme mit der ammoniakversorgung was
tatsächlich auch am Schornstein eine
Rolle spielt es gibt viele viele Hürden
wie im Moment zu überwinden sind und die
auch regulatorisch zu lösen sind und ich
kann Ihnen nur sagen als Mitglied einer
Fraktion die die Regierung trägt tun wir
Tag und Nacht alles dafür um zu
ermöglichen was geht und das würde ich
mir tatsächlich auch leider Gottes
halt nicht ausreichend gemacht und wie
die höchstenergiepreise zu sagen deshalb
ist es gut wir haben schon
aber wir haben schon mit den hohen
Energiepreisen schon eine Abwandlung
Industrie gehabt aber sie haben Recht
die Industrie hat sich nach Möglichkeit
die sich anpassen konnte sie angepasst
das Problem an der ganzen Sache ist da
die Preissteigerung von über 15 Jahre
statt genau
paar Wochen paar Monate statt und dann
noch mal ganz anders handeln deshalb
brauchen wir auch ein gaspreisdeckel
damit wir den Preis verrückt muss auch
displiziert werden und witzigerweise wir
könnten unseren gaspreisdeckel
problemlos finanzieren das können sie
mal ihrem Freund Herrn Winter sagen
indem er Fracking fördern und hinter die
Einnahme von Tracking in Deutschland
dazu nutzen um damit die Rechnung zu
bezahlen die wir jetzt für Subvention
von Gas aus mit dem Ratschlag erstellt
er an Frau Konrad und an Herr Lindner
gehen wir in eine ganz kurze
Unterbrechung und dann bin ich sehr
gespannt ob her Fahrt und Herr Schlögl
sich doch noch einig werden was die
Ukraine betrifft
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfen 5
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatjet Uschi der Wetten
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit wir sind
grün roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
vielleicht einmal kurz Einsatz also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall in meine lache immer bekommen
wer kümmert sich darum niemand bitte
ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
fair ist und nicht richtig Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und kommen direkt zu der
These von Herrn Professor Schlögl und
ich denke es ist nicht übertrieben zu
sagen dass er der Osteuropa Experte ist
ja
zur Situation es ist grauenhaft dass es
eines Krieges bedürfte der schon vor
langem angefangen hat um das größte Land
in Europa in unsere in unseren
Wahrnehmungshorizont überhaupt
aufzunehmen
es bedurfte eines Krieges um zu lernen
dass es Städte gibt und deshalb Charkiv
mariupold Kiew des bedurfte der
Zerstörung es bedürfte der Bomben es
bedürft eine Flüchtlingsbewegung die
zwischen ein Viertel der Bevölkerung
außer Landes getrieben hat um damit die
Europäer und die deutschen lernen dass
es außerhalb Russlands noch etwas
anderes gibt ein Land das nicht auf
unsere inneren Landkarte war und die
Frage ist wie kommt es eigentlich dass
es in Deutschland
keinen Raum gegeben hat für dieses große
und jetzt in Bedrängnis elementare
Bedrängnis geratene Land das hat etwas
mit einer
totalen Fixierung auf Russland zu tun
die man gut erklären kann es gibt
historische Beziehung es gibt die
Beziehung der Dynastien es gibt
kulturelle Beziehungen über Jahrhunderte
es gibt die große russische Literatur
die Kunst es gibt die frauenhafte
Erfahrung der beiden Völker der
deutschen der Russen in dem furchtbaren
Krieg in dem die Deutschen so viel
angerichtet haben aber Sie haben nicht
nur etwas in Russland angerichtet
sondern auf den Territorium der
Sowjetunion und das heißt die
Hauptschauplätze des Krieges waren wir
Larus und das war war die Ukraine und
die Frage ist wie kommt es eigentlich
dass die Deutschen so ausschließlich auf
Russland fixiert sind und das hat etwas
mit
Faszination für dieses große Land und
dieses reichen Land zu tun und es hat
etwas mit auch mit Schrecken und Angst
zu tun und zwischen diesen pendelt
eigentlich die deutsche Wahrnehmung
unentwegt und
heraus und es kommen noch viele Dinge
hinzu die Dankbarkeit das Gorbatschow
den der deutschen Wiedervereinigung
nicht den Weg gestanden hat sondern sie
befördert hat aber die Frage ist ob ihr
verstanden haben wie dieses Russland
nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion wirklich
tickt und ich glaube das ist eine
Wahrnehmung gibt die in gewisser Weise
von eingehüllt ist in
Sentimentalitäten in
die Erinnerung von verschiedenen
Generationen auch von Ahnungslosigkeit
also die Generation meine Generation in
der Regel die ist nie nach Russland
Gefahren in ostufe war das etwas anders
es gibt eigentlich keine große Kenntnis
des Landes und wie wie tickt ist und ich
glaube wir haben nun viel zu lange und
damit beschäftigt zu erklären dass der
Westen und die NATO schuld sein dass es
jetzt so in Russland gekommen ist und
das ist ein unglaublich bequemes und
einfaches Modell die Wahrheit ist man
muss sich erklären wie ein großes Land
nach dem Ende des Imperiums eine neue
Rolle findet und sich neu aufstellt und
diese Führung die putinische Führung hat
es nicht vermocht und er ist ein Fehling
men in gewisser Weise er hat es nicht
vermocht das Land aufzustellen für die
Modernisierung des Landes für eine
moderne Nationsbildung für eine für das
21 Jahrhundert sondern er hat den
einfachsten Weg gewählt der einfachste
Weg war Gas zu liefern Öl zu liefern
jetzt Getreide zu klauen und zu liefern
und jetzt sogar noch Menschen Menschen
sich anzueignen Manpower durch
Vertreibung durch Umsiedlung durch
Umvolkung und so weiter und diese
die Dynamik eines eines Landes den das
Reich abhanden gekommen ist zu verstehen
und die ungeheure Destruktivität die
darin besteht wenn es keinen Ausweg
gefunden hat und Putin hat das Land in
die Sackgasse geführt und das die
tragödis das Russland bis heute sich in
diese Sackgasse hat führen lassen was
ein eigenes Thema ist warum ist und
warum es soweit wir hatten wir einmal
fragen ja haben wir uns in Russland
getäuscht oder wie es auch war hatten
wir gar keine Ahnung von dem Land
ich glaube schon dass wir Russland immer
richtig eingeschätzt haben auch in der
Vergangenheit ich meine ich muss auch
sagen bei den Energielieferungen in
Russland das Frau Merkels Kurs richtig
war ja natürlich für halt ihn immer noch
für richtig mir fehlt einfach
deswegen überhaupt nicht dass das sage
ich aus Überzeugung wie es gibt in dem
Krieg so wie er jetzt abläuft einfach
keine militärische Lösung das ist der
Punkt und das wird einfach hier
übersehen in der Debatte wir haben eine
1200 km lange Frontlinie von Charkov im
Norden bis nach Carson das läuft da ab
da liegen sich die Parteien gegenüber
die Ukraine werden auch in Zukunft immer
begrenzte offensiven militärische
offensiven durchführen können weil sie
die amerikanischen Aufklärungsdaten
haben die Russen können quasi operativ
taktisch keine Überraschung herstellen
das geht nicht aufgrund der westlichen
Hilfe das ist ja auch richtig so das ist
alles in Ordnung aber da wird keine
Bewegung entstehen was wir jetzt haben
werden ist nach den Schein Referenden
eben ein stärkeren Guerillakrieg im
dombas nicht von den feindlichen Linien
das wird sicherlich jetzt das Thema der
nächsten Monate sein wenn wir das weiter
alimentieren militärisch das wollen wir
ja der Westen dann wird das ein langer
abnutzungskrieg und dann kann man am
Ende sagen jawohl militärisch
erfolgreich am Ende könnt ihr die
Ukraine sein so erfolgreich wie die
Taliban nach 20 Jahren
westlicher Truppen oder die muchaidin in
Afghanistan als die Sowjets dann doch
nach acht Jahren abziehen mussten oder
die Amerikaner wegen der wird kommen
welche also ich sag mal so eine
erfolgsmöglichkeit gibt es aber der
große Unterschied ist eben Russland ist
nicht Afghanistan Russland ist nicht
Libyen Russland ist nicht Irak nicht
Russland ist eine Atomart es geht nicht
ohne Russland eben es geht es geht ab
einfach nicht sie sind eine nuklear
macht sie sind die stärksten nuklearme
der Welt das heißt wenn Sie in diesem
Spektrum unterwegs sind militärisch
stehen sie immer vor der Möglichkeit des
Umschlags in ein allgemeinen dritten
weltkriegt
ernst nehmen das ist tatsächlich so
nicht und das muss man ernst nehmen das
kann man nicht einfach sagen auch der
läuft doch nur ich muss sagen
also wenn ich wenn ich sehe zum Beispiel
unsere ja also das muss ich auch
fairerweise sagen das Bundeskanzleramt
frei
und versucht da im Grunde genommen
einerseits Waffenlieferungen ja aber
eben doch so moderat dass es immer noch
uns Scholz ist auch der einzige der noch
von diplomatischen
Lösungsweg vor allem auch von vielen
Bundestagsabgeordneten die twittern dann
alles für die Ukraine die Ukraine muss
den Krieg gewinnen ich würde nicht sagen
oder würden Sie sagen dass im Bundestag
alle sagen Herr Scholz macht einen guten
Job und lieben diese Besonnenheit mir
kommt es eher so vor in der
Berichterstattung dass viele auch mit
Herrn Scholz hadern wegen seiner
Besonnenheit in der Sache oder würden
Sie nicht zustimmen ich glaube die
mediale Aufgeregtheit die wir oft
erleben bringt er auch manche zu Unrecht
in Verdacht ich erlebe herr Scholz als
sehr besonnen und würde mal ein bisschen
anderen Blick darauf werfen auf dem Land
Russland dem die Leute weglaufen es geht
ja hier um einen Krieg auch gegen Werte
gegen Werte die die Ukraine sich
erarbeitet ja erwirtschaftet hat im
Laufe der Jahre um Frieden Freiheit und
auch Wohlstand in einem sozialen
marktwirtschaftlichen System auf das sie
sich einlassen wollten die
das glaube ich auch dass man diesen Weg
beschreiten wollte und jetzt haben wir
eine Situation in der Friede und
Freiheit in Europa wieder angegriffen
werden und tatsächlich in ein System
also wo kommen wir denn dahin wenn jeder
hier jeden wieder annektieren kann wie
das irgendwann vor vor
Jahrhunderten der Fall war also ich
glaube hier auch mal einen Strich zu
ziehen und sagen dieses Land ist eben
nicht erfolgreich mit seiner
Lösungsvorschlag Frau Konrad ist eben
nicht erfolgreich mit seiner Strategie
die es gerade fährt weil ihm die jungen
Männer jetzt weglaufen weil die Leute
das auch nicht mehr mitmachen im Land
weil natürlich auch ein
Wohlstandsverlust
einhergeht müssen wir hier auch weiter
dabei der Linie bleiben und die Ukraine
in jedem Fall unterstützt was ist ihr
Lösungsvorschlag welche sagen ja was ist
denn gesagt die Ukraine muss in jedem
Fall weiter auch unterstützt werden das
ist der Weg den die Bundesrepublik
eingeschlagen hat und der auch weiter
verfolgt wird und wie gesagt Sie haben
sie haben ja eben Herr Schlögl sehr
schön auch die die historischen
Zusammenhänge herausgearbeitet und ich
glaube das ist wirklich eine ganz ganz
schwierige Situation in Bezug auf den
energiekrieg den wir jetzt vor der
eigenen Haustür erleben und den wir
lösen müssen die Lösung ist wir müssen
unsere eigenen Hausaufgaben jetzt viel
schneller machen und tatsächlich die
Krisen hier auch in unserem eigenen Land
bewältigen und Lösungen finden so dass
unser eigenes so dass die Bevölkerung
hier auch auch also das ist nochmal ganz
klar wir haben ja alle Konsens dass
selbst über Angriff überhaupt nicht okay
war da haben wir glaube ich alle Konsens
ist aber ganz darüber zu betonen
ihr müsst ich schon sehen ist weil sie
gerade wir müssen jetzt zu gewinnen und
es hat so aus es ist natürlich
Putin hat ja durchaus ein paar Trümpfe
in der Hand und jetzt kann man sagen
militärisch spielt ist es nicht gut
gelaufen militärisch damit alles
korrigieren
militärisch ist ja unter Druck hat im
Prinzip immer noch dieses druckpotenzial
mit dem Atomwaffen aber auf der anderen
Seite die Zeit spielt auch für ihn mit
der Bereitschaft der europäischen
Bevölkerungen weiter Kurs zu halten und
wenn er jetzt die Energiekrise sich
verschärft wenn wir wirtschaftliche
Probleme konnte kriegen dieses Jahr
nicht Rezession in Europa das ist halt
seit ich sagen alle Institute auch
weltweit dann kommt der Druck immer mehr
und deshalb ist es natürlich so wenn wir
wirklich sagen wir sind hier in diesem
Konflikt im großen Konflikt mit Russland
und wir wollen Putin Schwächen dann
müssen wir
holen mich jetzt da die Energiepreise
weltweit runter kriegen und das muss die
Priorität sein und wenn wir das nicht
machen wenn ihr Energiepreise hoch
bleiben wird die Unzufriedenheit wachsen
es kann man sagen okay in Deutschland
wird es dann so passiert dass dann die
die auf die Straßen gehen die werden
dann gleich
kritisiert aber ich glaube europaweit
bitte schwierig sein wir kommen jetzt
einmal zur These von der Fahrt der
aucheinlösungsvorschlag mitgebracht hat
oder auf jeden Fall wie wir uns
verhalten sollten ja ich glaube es ist
besser es ist schon richtig das Russland
in einer machtpolitisch gesehen
bedenklichen Situation ist wir müssen
auf deutsch gesagt langfristig den
Abstieg Russlands als Weltmacht managen
denn demografisch gehen sie in den
Keller sie sind von ihrem Gas und Öl nur
abhängig auf Dauer halten Sie diesen
Status nicht durch das hat ja Präsident
Obama schon richtig erkannt ob das
politisch klug war damals das ist
dahingestellt sein das ist ja vollkommen
klar und dass dieser Akt in der Ukraine
völkerrechtswürdig war auch ist auch
klar welchen dass wir den Ukraine eben
helfen ist auch in Ordnung aber wir
müssen das politisch klüger machen ich
wir dürfen nicht einseitig auf
Waffenlieferungen setzen wir dürfen
nicht
davon ausgehen dass wir eine
militärische Lösung hier herbei Bomben
werden und das dann alle nach Hause
gehen und dann ist Frieden wir müssen
versuchen aus dieser militärischen
eskalationslogik irgendwann rauszukommen
weil das Risiko eines Dritten
Weltkrieges eines nukleakrieges massiv
hoch ist in Afghanistan konnten wir nach
Hause gehen nach 20 Jahren wir hatten
tausende von Soldaten verloren es hat
es hat Millionen Millionen
nicht da konnten wir einfach gehen das
geht hier nicht ja und Russland kann da
auch nicht raus aus der Box der steht da
mit Rücken vor der Wand wenn er dort
rausgeht ist Russland am Ende ist nicht
nur Putin am Ende das geht nicht
Stichwort Sicherheitsbedürfnisse stärker
beachten strategische Interessen in der
Region auch sehen ja das sind unsere
strategischen Interessen wann sind die
Russlands der Ukraine der Amerikaner ja
es ist natürlich ein Freiheitskampf
eines Volkes was man unterstützen muss
aber es ist auch ein Stellvertreter
Krieg zwischen den USA und Russland der
da läuft da geht es um geostrategische
Interessen handfester Art genauso wie
die Chinesen das im Südchinesischen Meer
haben oder die Türken die auch parallel
Krieg führen im Nordirak und Syrien
gegen die Kurden über jemand redet
einmal gerne einmal gerne hinstellen und
seine Einschätzung bitten Sie sehen ja
ganz viele Sachen anders als Herr Vater
aber haben wir denn als Deutschland
überhaupt die Chance aktiv einzugreifen
ja wir haben die Chance ich bin nämlich
den Ukrainern beizustehen in ihrem Kampf
für die Existenz und das Überleben ihres
Staates und ihres Volkes
diese Möglichkeit haben wir und deswegen
ist die Lieferung von Waffen richtig und
wir sollten so viel liefern wie möglich
dass man weiter diplomatische Kanäle
versucht zu errichten und zu bespielen
das ist der vollständig klar das ist
geradezu banal dass man das alles tut
aber dazu gehört auch dass man die den
Bankrott in gewisser Weise der
Diplomatie gegenüber dem was die
russische Politik in den letzten zehn
Jahren war dass man das mal analysiert
dass man analysiert warum die Putin die
eskalationsdominanz behalten hat und bis
auf den heutigen Tag und die
eskalationsdominanz besteht darin dass
er ein Teil der Ukraine jetzt zum
Staatsgebiet Russlands erklärt und jede
Verteidigung der Ukraine jede
Verteidigung durch keinem zu einem
Angriff auf Russland erklärt und damit
und die mit den Atomwaffen droht das und
da möchte ich wissen von Leuten die
immer nach der diplomatischen
Lösung das ist für mich ich möchte
wissen wer bringt jemanden an den Tisch
an den Diplo an den Verhandlungstisch
den den Tisch umgeworfen hat und der
überhaupt nicht die Bereitschaft ja
Schlögl in der Logik müssten sie halt
weiter kämpfen dann viel Spaß ne ich
sehe nur die militärische Lösung da eben
nicht und das ist eben der Punkt Mosche
Dajan hat das übrigens mal gesagt er war
ein ziemlich knallharter israelischer
general ich selber kurz was sagen Ton
nur noch kennengelernt und er hat
er hat die Araber wirklich von Herzen
gehasst und abgelehnt und er hat Kriege
gegen arabische Länder geführt die
Israel damals angegriffen haben aber er
war der erste Außenminister Israels der
gesagt hat wir müssen Frieden machen mit
ihnen und er hat kann sehr stark unter
Druck in der innerparteilich auch und er
hat dann mal gesagt ja wenn du Frieden
willst reicht es nicht mit deinen
Freunden zu reden du musst mit deinem
Feind reden bei jeder Geiselnahme ja
macht man das vielleicht große
Staatsmänner ja ich denke mal die
Schlüssel sag ich mal liegen natürlich
nicht gerade in Berlin und in Brüssel
das schon richtig weil ich also der das
ist schon eher eine Sache der USA und da
wünschte ich mir dann auch von
Deutschland ein bisschen mehr Druck in
diese Richtung ich meine ja unser
Kanzler sollte auch mal nach Washington
fliegen und auch mal mit den Amerikanern
reden weil wir müssen ja gemeinsame
Lösung finden mit unserem wichtigsten
Bündnispartner da raus aber da brauchen
wir profitieren auch gerade die
Amerikaner liefern Waffen verkaufen
Waffen große Stil die Amerikaner haben
sind ein Netto energieexporteur für die
sind hohe Energiepreise super also bei
der Amerikaner ist es eigentlich super
die haben genau einen kleinen Rivalen
fertig machen die einzige Frage die ich
über den einen Pool nie verstehen
verstanden habe ist warum die Amerikaner
ist als Ziel haben könnten das Russland
und China aneinander rücken weil
das ist auch so dieser Nebeneffekt wo
ich auch sage wir machen alles natürlich
für die Ukraine das ist ja auch in
Ordnung es geht hier nur um die Frage
wie viel und wie wie klug ist es und wie
weit gehen wirst was wir aber auch
machen ist wir treiben die Russen
regelrecht in die Arme der Chinesen
nicht das verschlechtert unsere
geopolitisch geostrategische Lage ja
auch weil ich hier würde ich gerne noch
einmal ähm Schlögl eine eine Frage habe
ich und zwar
viele Fragen sicher ich weiß Mutmaßungen
das möchten wir auch gar nicht mehr
viele fragen sich ja wie weit entfernt
das Kriegsende ist oder wie nah ist da
möglich eine Prognose zu sehen ob der
Krieg noch ein halbes Jahr geht ob der
Krieg noch zehn Jahre geht ob da wie da
das Zeitfenster ist also wir sind keine
Propheten wie der Kassandra noch Profit
wir wissen es nicht wir wissen nicht
einmal was morgen und übermorgen
passiert und das müsste Herr ward am
besten wissen er hat ja den Überfall
kommentiert
ja er hat ja kommentiert und was mir
auffällt an diese Diskussion es ist
wieder überhaupt nicht die Rede davon
was in Russland vor sich geht es
passiert etwas worauf ihr auch nicht
gefasst waren das hunderttausende
300.000 junge Menschen sind in den
letzten zehn Tagen an die Grenzen
gefahren und sind ausgefallen wegen der
mobil machen es hat in Dagestan in
Jakutien gutes Demonstrationen gegeben
es hat in vielen Städten
Manifestationen gegeben es passiert
etwas worauf wir die wir alle schon uns
daran gewöhnt haben zu glauben das Putin
der Mann der die Stabilität garantiert
nein er ist nicht der Mann der die
Stabilität garantiert sondern der die
Zerstörung Russlands als eines Staates
betreibt er führte das Land in den
Abgrund übrigens
raus weil unsere Sendezeit ist vorbei
ist doch ein schöner Hoffnung schon mal
zu sehen dass in der ersten
schönen Abend noch und wir sehen uns
morgen abend wieder tschüss
[Musik]